depuis deux ans le célèbre bistrot où
travaillent et amélie poulain est
devenue un lieu de pèlerinage
presque au même titre que l'arc de
triomphe où le sacré coeur
c'est vrai j'ai vu le film trois fois et
j'ai aussi le dessin alors quelle
émotion dans le quartier en apprenant la
vente du café des deux moulins
aussi sont ils sont sympas ils sont
restés simples vous voyez le bail et
cherche pas à augmenter le prix de leur
café mais n'importe quoi il faut qu'il
reste avec le même état d'esprit la même
la même disposition c'est à dire que
c'est ça fait partie un peu des
monuments je dirais par historique de
notre e mais presque avec ses glaces et
ses néons cette maison simple des années
50 dispose désormais d'une renommée
mondiale
alors devant tant de réactions le patron
en général discret se sentent obligés de
réconforter des fan d'amélie son
acheteur n'a pas été choisi au hasard qu
il veut conserver le lieu dans l'état et
surtout pas faire de travaux car il
adore le décor dans les cinq ans qui
plaît énormément d'ailleurs et il a eu
le coup de coeur comme moi quand je suis
arrivé sur 80,6
pas un mot sur le montant de la vente
mais dans ce quartier typique qui
drainait déjà de nombreux touristes
l'effet amélie s'est fait sentir pour
tous les commerçants certains ont même
tendance à voir les choses en grand
comme le monde le regarde comme violent
qu'on le déclare même monument
historique
soyez donc rassurés montmartre restera
montmartre et avec un peu de chance la
crème dessert amélie continuera à faire
le bonheur de nos amis japonais de 2,6
je suis très content d'être envoyés ici